i saw that you got a chance
uh to call richard feynman a mentor of
yours when you were at caltech
yeah uh do you have any fond memories of
feynman
any lessons that stick with you oh yeah
he was quite a character
uh and one of the deepest thinkers of
all time probably
and at least in my life the physicist
who had the single
most intuitive understanding of how
nature works
of anyone i've met uh he
i learned a number of things from him he
was not my thesis advisor i worked with
wallace sergeant at caltech on
what are called active galaxies big
black holes in the centers of galaxies
that are
accreting or swallowing material a
little bit like the stuff of
of this year's nobel prize in physics
2020.
uh but feynman i had for for two courses
one was general theory of relativity at
the graduate level
and one was applications of quantum
physics to all kinds of
interesting things and he
you know he had this very intuitive way
of
of looking at things that he tried to
that he tried to bring to his students
and he felt that
if you can't explain something in a
reasonably simple way
to a non-scientist or at least
you know someone who is versed a little
bit with science but is not
a professional scientist then you
probably don't
understand it very well yourself very
thoroughly
so that in me um
you know made a desire to un to to be
able to explain science to the to the
general public and i've often found that
in explaining things
yeah there's a certain part that i
didn't really understand myself that's
one reason i like to teach the
introductory courses to the lay public
is that i sometimes find that my
explanations are lacking in my own mind
you know
so he did that for me is there uh if i
could just
pause for a second yeah you said he had
one of the most intuitive understanding
of
nature yeah what if you could break
apart what intuitive means
like it is that on the philosophical
level no
sort of physical how do you draw a
mental
picture or a picture on paper of what's
going on and
he's perhaps most famous in this regard
for his feynman diagrams which
in what's called quantum electrodynamics
a quantum field theory of electricity
and magnetism
what you have are actually you know an
exchange of photons between
charged particles and they might even be
virtual photons
if the particles are at rest relative
to one another and there are ways of
doing calculations that are
brute force that take pages on pages and
pages of calculations
and julian schwinger developed some of
the mathematics for that and won the
nobel prize for it
but feynman had these diagrams that he
made and he had a set of rules of what
to do at
the vertex you'd have two particles
coming together and then a particle
going out and then
two particles coming out again and he'd
have these rules associated when there
were vertices and when there were
particles splitting off from one another
and all that and it looked a little bit
like a bunch of a hodgepodge at first
but to those who
learned the rules and understood them he
you know they
they saw that you could do these complex
calculations in a much
simpler way and indeed in some ways
freeman dyson had
an even better knack for explaining
really what quantum electrodynamics
actually was but i didn't know freeman
dyson i i knew fineman maybe he did have
a more intuitive view of the world than
feynman did but of the people i knew
find one was the
most intuitive most sort of is there a
picture is there a simple way you can
understand
this and in in um in
the path that a particle follows even
you know you can figure out the
you can get the classical path at least
you know for a baseball or something
like that
by using quantum physics if you want but
you know in a sense the baseball sniffs
out
all possible paths it goes out to the
andromeda galaxy and then goes to the
to the batter but the probability of
doing that is very very small because
tiny little paths next door to any given
path
cancel out that path and the ones that
all
add together they they are the ones that
are
more likely to be followed and this
actually ties in with
fairmont's principle of least action and
there are ideas in optics that go into
this as well and
and it just sort of beautifully brings
everything together but
the particle sniffs out all possible
paths
what a crazy idea but if you do the
mathematics associated with that
it ends up being actually useful
a useful way of looking at the world
you